you know those times when you've gotten
into trouble but you never realized your
idea was bad until it was too late but
sort of like what happened a stock fish
in this game on the white side of a
King's Indian stock fish always liked
it's a position according to the
evaluation bar you'll see in this video
but alpha zero had other ideas in mind
the game starts off in the King's Indian
and stock fish chooses to face it with
the same ish variation and this is seen
as very solid the pawn on f3 defends the
pawn on e4 it also prevents any black
piece from going to the g4 square as
well the pawn defends it so castles
Bishop III c5 all this is theory this is
not a pawn blunder it's just a temporary
sacrifice often where black gets
sufficient compensation and in practice
does quite well it's a 92 96 and now d5
to attack the knight and all of these
moves make perfect sense the policy
forwards hangings on IG 3 protects it
and e 6 when you have less space you
tend to want fewer pieces to remain on
the board because otherwise your piece
are stepping on each other's toes
so Bishop b2 trades and h5 then they
don't g3 not a great piece and black can
expand on the kingside kick that night
out of the g3 square and potentially
initiate a King side attack castles h4 9
h1 only Square and ugly square of course
your Knights in the corner but it's
gonna quickly get back into the game via
Knight f2 now Knight h7 makes a lot of
sense here trying to go pawn to f5 you
want to chisel away at White's very
good-looking center and then get some
counter play now alpha0 played a move
that I would not play in a game but
maybe now I would that I've seen this
one h3 because I would fear that that
pawn has gone too far
the only piece defending it is this
Bishop on c8 and if this pawn moves
later to g4 and the night comes to f2
that pawn may be a goner now also look
at the evaluation on the left side of
the board here 1.17 in whites favors to
stock fish which is the engine that the
chess camp server uses
likes the position of course unit
analyzes position and more depth but it
says that white is better but alpha zero
doesn't believe that g3 was played
Bishop d7 rook c1 and now B five a
thematic move saying that please take
this pawn if you take on b5 with the
night I just go rook to b8 and my rook
is coming down into the position on b2
so just to show a sample variation of
what can happen is Knight d6 rook takes
b2 and let's say you keep trying to take
my pawns with Bishop takes e5 so white
is temporarily up two pawns but black
has great counter chances of the move
like Bishop to a4 the bishop on e 2 is
gonna be captured if you move your queen
and take on a4 which you have to do
because if you play Queen e1 here comes
a beautiful shot Knight to d3 now if you
take on d3 which if you don't do that
you're just losing all the material here
comes rook you to check and mate so that
would just be absolutely devastating so
you know Queen takes a 4 just to show a
sample line rook f2 trying to fend off
this rook on the second rank then Knight
takes f3 check comes and you see this
evaluation bar sort of swinging here
black is gonna be the one who is just
completely crushing and now you see
finally the evaluation bar continues to
sink and that shows that black is the
one in charge
so after b5 no capture 9f2 but here's
sort of the depth that it seems like
black is in danger of overextending
because we'll see rook e8 still don't
want to take that pawn on b5 and after
king h1 is getting the King what looks
like to safety b4 Knight b1 and black
has some structural issues here
this Knight is trying to quickly plug
the c-4 square and from c4 it hits the
d6 and it trades away blacks best pieces
95 but check this move out BAM Knight e
to g4 I was not anticipating at all when
I was first shown this game because what
kind of move is that you're giving up
your night for what looks like just one
on but the evaluations is 1.3 and whites
favor right now
again that's silly stockfish but look
how quickly the dynamic league game
changes pawn G 494 now all of a sudden
of threatening Knight takes g3 with
check over here and once that pawn is
captured then I can take your III Bishop
with my rook right so all of a sudden
lions are opening up in blacks favor not
to mention that this Bishop on g7 has a
new lease on the board because the b2
pawn is hanging so trade on e4 Bishop f4
ok coming after the d6 pawn so Queen e7
protects Bishop f3 and now Bishop takes
b2 so offering a series of trades
because now all of a sudden black has
two pawns for the piece and this g4 pawn
might fall next so that would be a third
pawn so Bishop takes d6 taking one pawn
back Queen d6 Bishop b4 and we see that
black currently has just one pawn for
the night but it's not the quantity of
pieces that alpha Zira is sniffing out
here it's the quality of them because
look at the play here this should be 5
hanging the rook on f1 the rook moves
rook to e8 sort of pinning this bishop
the bishop was no we're good to go and
black is just trying to push this c5
pawn down to the c3 squared
when you have a passer you want to keep
advancing it Knight d2 c4 what didn't I
teach you to do to stop them move
absolutely nothing if you take on c4
you're just gonna lose very quickly
because up to Queen c5 my Queens coming
to f2 I'm 92 Queen f2 and you can't stop
me from sacrificing my rook on the e4
square in which case you're gonna have
problems on the light squares so it's
gonna be Czech and mating ideas so
Knight takes e4 doesn't work that's a
Knight f3 and it looks like alpha 0
plotted this out to equality because
again white is still a material so if
black isn't doing something quick white
will just consolidate and win so Queen
f4 ignoring the Queen trade between c5
actually avoiding instead of ignoring
five in a rookie seven so calmly
defending the f7 square the pawn from c3
can push the c2 it a moment's notice and
White's King is still not very happy
they're trapped in the corner so Queen
f6 c2 threatening c1 equals Queen and
Knight takes g6 a blasting open blacks
King but this just fizzles out very
quickly so alpha zero can just take it
and d6 is one last-ditch effort just
trying to you know it would confuse a
human but these are not human right
these are engines here we're working
their magic so Bishop h7 check okay you
could take it either way but the point
is now it's just a series of checks
since the game ended with a million
checks so this part of the game we're
just going back and forth until it's
natural conclusion of a draw so a really
fascinating game this one was
sacrificing the knight of the G
Foursquare catching me by surprise
perhaps catching the stockfish
developers by surprise but alpha zero
really plotted this ahead I mean this
was something fascinating and just
getting to the game's conclusion you
might as well show you the rest here as
it was just a bunch of checks and the
evaluation bar is just sticking at zero
because the King can't escape all these
checks so the draw was finally reached
but just to go back and emphasize one
last time for all the viewers here is
that you know you get this position you
know the plan is to go b5 but it's not
clear that and move like Knight e to g4
will ever work so if you don't capture
my pawn on b5 then once I get before in
this Bishop on g7 opens up the whole
position opens up and black had just
enough play there to hold the balance so
a phenomenal move just to show that on
the board once more Knight e to g4 I
mean that's for the highlight reel a
full-piece sacrifice get a couple pawns
but the counter play the momentum gained
was enough to hold the balance a really
nice showing by alpha zero taking
advantage of that kind of critical
calculation that
really deep plan that no engine is
seeing several moves in advance